the turkish donald trump
i think that's what they they call my
opponent
so i'm just gonna go for classical d4c4
knight f3
um probably gonna see some kind of
queens gambit
basically my main report you are
just playing my main stuff
see what it's got so castle castles it
is a little bit unusual there
especially connected with c c6
i think when you go for c6 um
you don't really want to have the bishop
on for
for whatever reason those moves don't
connect well and i think one of the
reasons is that bishop b4 is
is an active move that needs to be
followed up actively with
with c5 kind of play and once you go for
c6 i think the bishop is generally
better off on
on e7 or d6 because here it's really
not hitting anything um basically
whenever he would
chop off my knight on on c on c3 then
that would just improve my pawn
structure with bc
or in this case rook c3 just giving up a
knight for
a bishop um and uh
there's also there's also this pin from
the bishop on g5 the queen on d8
and you really would like to see the
bishop break that pin
so i think in my opponent's shoes i
would definitely recommend push b7
which he has done so
i would say to that move uh nicely done
that was a good move
so i'm going to go for something that
might look
a little counter intuitive here which is
just to exchange an f6
the idea though is either after knight
if f6 or
um or else also bishop f6 i want to go
knight
knight to e4 and uh try and
clamp down on the c5 square it may have
been more
accurate though maybe more accurate to
play queen c2
first hitting hitting h7 forcing g6 or
h6
and then um
and then playing knight e4 so queen c7
uh is in general a decent move but
i think um
as um as an experienced player
you will learn that putting the um
the queen into the x-ray of an
opponent's rook
is usually a bad idea obviously there
are
going to be a bunch of exceptions but
generally
you're not going to be very successful
with that and in this case he just lost
the pawn
and yeah 95
there's queen b6 and then c5 is gonna
come and he's gonna freeze game
just a tad so let me try and play a
little
bit more accurately now in case of queen
b6 i have other alternatives like
queen b3 and also queen c2 further
clamping down on c5
you can also go a i can also go b4
no i cannot do that because b4 would run
into
queen b4 take it um
rook big one and queen e7 so it goes
queen e7 immediately
which i have to say is an excellent move
um
yeah it's a really good move in turning
c5
and in case of c5 would he would still
be upon down
but
he has considerably if that were
happening has considerably improved his
prospects
so i'm going to go for something a
little bit unusual here
which is rook c5 and in case of knight
e4
knights d7 i'm just going to go rook a5
attack that pawn and hopefully gain some
time and
uh for me it's it's all about it's all
about
clamping down on c6 that is both a weak
pawn
and it's also holding back his bishop on
b7
if i can clamp down on that i have a
winning position
otherwise i probably don't have much of
an advantage a lot at all
so i think he played this mistakenly um
[Music]
he he went for bish base six and now c6
is just hanging
and although it is said that by
losing one of your weak pawns you always
get some activity for
your pieces i think in this case the
activity is going to be
is going to be quite short-lived queen
a4
and i'm asking him asking him
really where is he going to put his
bishop on d3 it's going to be hit by
knight e5
if um bishop b7 there would be a queen
a7 with a pin
so it really was a great
question to to which there was no good
answer
okay let me just go bishop f3 knight c6
is coming next trying to win the pawn on
a7
and uh
and it's looking it's looking fairly
grim for my opponent here
but as i as i said in the the previous
game
like my opponent is not making major
mistakes at all
it's just um there are some
some some small positional and also
occasionally tactical mistakes that in
the long run
makes makes a lot of difference so i
could go queen c5
but i actually rather like queen e7
just actually
smothering his queen as far as i can see
forcing a queen exchange and then that's
going to be
that's going to be three pawns up two of
them
passed sorry two of them connected
passers i'm going to take
i should have gone king h7 but it
doesn't really matter much
now rook c8 next um
is is the threat just
forcing off more pieces from the board
and um
you know when you're a lot of material
up just
thinning the fields it's a good idea
just been in winning the field
and win with as little
effort as possible right that's what you
want to do
so the pawns go marching on
knight d6 let me just calculate king f8
b5 king e7 i can go for the pawn ending
with b6 but
is that really that really instructive
though
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna bring
more more people to the party just
support my knight on d6
and then and then push the pawns
i could take an f7 but
where would the instructional value be
in that huh
now yeah i don't don't know why he
psyched the knight there but it doesn't
matter
doesn't matter in the slightest
[Music]
okay yeah at the end obviously night up
and
skiing is tied down uh completely
winning
good game for my opponent but as you can
see
i'm not i'm not taking any prisoners so
far
against these lower rated players i just
wanna
i wanna talk but i also want to win